Welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my new Marvel phase 5 Avengers
5 video there's a new report about
Marvel's plans for how they're planning
on setting up the road map leading to
Avengers 5 in the New Avengers roster so
we'll break it all down there's a whole
bunch of Easter eggs we actually know a
lot about what's happening during Marvel
phase 5 right now if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we're doing the Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and let me know what you
want that new Avengers roster to be
whatever it takes whatever it takes no
fears no regrets part of the journey so
just going down the list here number 5
if you didn't see the news there's a
report that Captain Marvel 2 is going to
be Marvel's new version of Captain
America's Civil War in the way that they
set up the next Avengers movie the way
the Captain America Civil War sort of
set the stage for Avengers infinity war
samuel l.jackson did say that Nick Fury
has another team to put together he's
considering right now on his sword Space
Station you can see some of the
connections to the Nick Fury character
very tied to the Captain Marvel
character all the Skrulls running around
in the background on that Space Station
also very tied to the Captain Marvel
character so it makes sense that they
would use her movie as sort of a setup
for the next big Avengers movie there
are a couple other big movies coming out
that year so we'll talk about what's
going on with black panther 2 and how
that's also probably going to set up the
next Avengers movie so what's the Marvel
phase 5 timeline in terms of Avengers 5
release date which characters would be
involved who is that New Avengers team
if there are six original Avengers who
are the six new avengers going to be if
the sword Space Station is going to be
the launching platform for the next
Avengers team and it's going to be a
space based threat what is the story of
Avengers five going to be what about new
x-men characters what about new
Fantastic Four characters we're talking
deep Marvel phase five so we'll probably
have already met some of those new
characters and who's going to direct
Avengers 5 if the Russos aren't quite
ready to come back yet they did say they
would eventually come back to do more
Marvel movies but it would have to be
the right movie in according to them the
right movie meant either marbles new
x-men movie or Avengers Secret Wars so
for who is that new team like I said if
there are six original Avengers with a
few extras
characters not counting infinity war an
Avengers endgame because everybody got
to be in those movies you have to think
a little bit smaller for Avengers 5 just
a main Avengers roster with a bunch of
other side characters running around so
we'll just think about the main six
right now you have spider-man who
graduated to full blown Avenger during
infinity war he'll also be a couple
years older by now in college for those
you that are waiting for a
twenty-something spider-man instead of
the high school spider-man will call him
number one and because Tony Stark named
him his heir apparent he's sort of
replacing Iron Man on the team
breathe a sigh of relief too because
Sony said that they would continue
sharing the character with Marvel
indefinitely however many contracts that
they have to re-sign with Marvel so it's
not a really huge concern
Chris Hemsworth claims that he wants to
come back as Thor so he's probably
sticking around
Mark Ruffalo claims that he wants to
stick around as the Hulk so he's
probably sticking around Doctor Strange
we know is sticking around Black Panther
is probably going to be replacing
Captain America on the team and bringing
Cherie with him even though she's kind
of a side character then obviously
Captain Marvel 2 is setting the stage
for what's happening during Avengers 5
she'll be on the team too replacing
Black Widow that makes the 6 mains
there's going to  be a bunch of other
characters in the movie but there'll be
lesser characters in there also be
introducing some brand new characters to
talking about x-men characters big
Fantastic Four characters but 3 what is
the story of Avengers 5 so if Captain
Marvel 2 is reportedly setting things up
like I said the threat the villain would
have to be from outer space that's why
you would need to be on that sword Space
Station is sort of justifies his
existence to the whole reason for the
sword agency in the comics existing is
to protect Earth from threats from outer
space and Captain Marvel spends most of
her time on an orbital space station
protecting Earth from outer space they
could do anihilation conquest the main
villain to that is a nihilist you just
call it avengers annihilation you could
do Avengers Galactus if they want a fast
track the Galactus storyline the coming
of Galactus was a fantastic for a
three-part storyline where silver surfer
showed up and basically told the
Fantastic Four Galactus is coming to end
your world there was a really big Kree
Secret Invasion teaser during spider-man
far from home when Nick Fury the fake
Nick Fury who is really Talos of the
scrolls was talking about secret Kree
sleeper cells
I really caught it went off the rails
and so we need you to come back because
everyone kept asking me where the
Avengers are I don't know what the cider
that's so I think Secret Invasion is
also pretty high on the list if the
story of Captain Marvel too isn't
already Secret Invasion I think it's a
little too soon for Avengers vs. x-men
or Avengers secret Wars I know a lot of
people heard the rumor that rogue is
going to show up during Captain Marvel
too and they want rogue to get her
powers like she did in the comics even
if you're not a big x-men comic book
reader you probably remember x-men the
animated series on that series rogue
could fly the reason in the comics why
she could fly is because she took
Captain Marvel's powers remember she can
leech powers from other people she did
that to Captain Marvel in the comics d
powered Captain Marvel who then actually
joined an x-men team for a little while
so Captain Marvel did crossover with the
x-men but that's just a rumor it would
be a cool Easter Egg if there was a
rogue in the MCU that then leached some
of Captain Marvel's powers and gained
the ability to fly what about the
timeline when would Avengers 5 be
released it's going to be a may spring
movie no matter what year it comes out
and if they're pacing things out the way
they did for Avengers infinity war that
came out two years after Captain America
Civil War so look at this schedule here
if Captain Marvel 2 is coming out July
2022 Avengers 5 would either have to be
May 2023 or May 2024 I think a lot of
that just depends on how fast they want
to release their new Fantastic Four in
their new x-men reboot movies because
one of those at least feels like it
would be a May movie so they want a fast
track the New Avengers movie they could
just release it May 2023 but obviously
not before then I know you're all asking
about Black Panther 2 that's probably
going to be an enormous film how is that
going to set up Avengers 5 well one of
the rumors for why Marvel waited for
years since the first Black Panther
movie to release it is because they want
the MCU to be ready for a new x-men and
Fantastic Four characters to cross over
they also kind of got into a spot of
trouble with Ryan Coogler contract
renegotiation they only signed him to do
that first black panther movie and when
it did gangbusters and they wanted him
back so bad he was able to rake them
over the coals on his contract renewal
he totally deserves it I hope he gets
paid for black panther 2
there's been a lot of talk about who's
going to direct Avengers five they could
always bring in fresh meat for the
grinder a director that they've never
worked with before I think it's a little
more likely that they would look to
someone that they know already and has
done a giant movie but because the ruses
aren't coming back that only includes
James Gunn Taika Waititi Jon Favreau
Ryan Coogler Joss Whedon so you guys can
let me know in the comments looking at
the list of directors that Marvel has
let me know who you want to direct
Avengers 5 if it's not going to be the
Russos but number one what is that
Avengers 5 post-credits scene going to
be the Thanos Infinity Gauntlet level
teaser that they drop at the end setting
out the next big saga just talking about
early predictions what I hope that they
do is they actually just either go for
the slam-dunk easy Galactus win and just
have Silver Surfer show up in the post
credit scene letting you know that
Galactus is coming your Herald summons
you another world awaits. Let it be done quickly.
or if they want to start setting up
their multiverse Ark for Secret Wars
they just have a major character that
we've seen before show up from an
alternate universe and destroy an
alternate reality sort of setting off
the time runs out storyline if you
didn't read the lead-up to Marvel's
Secret Wars a couple years ago what
happened is is that you have Doctor
Strange in some of the Illuminati
basically trying to destroy other
realities to protect their reality as
things slowly winnow their way down to
the one battle world so you have a lot
of alternate reality versions of the
characters trying to fight for their
reality destroying other realities so
you have a bunch of alternate Avengers
team some of them good some of them evil
trying to kill each other
so that their own earth won't be
destroyed then after it's all done you
have the beginnings of the actual secret
war storyline if it looks like they're
going to set something that big up then
I'll do a much bigger video about that
it's a really complicated storyline it
could be really cool if they can pull it
off there's also the classic secret war
storyline which is much smaller that's
just the Beyonder transporting all the
Marvel characters to a world to fight
each other to see who the strongest is
that's a good question to leave it on
let me know in the comments would you
rather than do the more recent secret
Wars storyline as their next big saga
infinity war endgame level of
or would you rather than do something
like the smaller original Secret Wars
which also kind of helps set up the
symbiotes saga for spider-man because
eventually they probably will want to do
a symbiote saga for him I'll do more
Avengers 5 videos when we get more
details about what's going on with that
but it's so far off in the future don't
expect to hear too much about that right
now mostly they're just setting up all
the Marvel phase 4 movies and there will
be a bunch of that happening later this
year congratulations
soul veil 88 you're the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your details
everyone click here for my breakdown of
the new title for spider-man 3 in the
sinister six movie and click here for my
black panther 2 teaser Easter eggs video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe I'll see you guys tonight!